so actually may know I'm not working
with Disney anyway it's had great
consequences for my career where I'm
heading in life what choices do I make
what people can I trust a lot of
questions have a rose from this but
there's one good thing out of all this
just one one thing one thing that I can
honestly say has been a positive change
now I can finally play my favorite game
frozen and I give birth a baby I'd be
wanting to play this game for the
longest time but I've never been able to
do it cuz Disney doesn't want it love
the music love everything let's play hey
oh boy I had to private my other frozen
videos spin hidden spin hidden since
2015 fetus foetus
oh sorry foetus ECG monitor okay it
doesn't know it doesn't go there okay oh
here we go here we go I got something we
did it okay now we got to give her the
drugs just relax
you're gonna fall asleep and never wake
up again
now we add a little bit of magic a
little bit of magic
there you go sprinkle all the magic on
that Billie and then we're gonna cut
that [ __ ] open sorry sorry gotta let a
little bit of magic
there you go baby
hey circumcised no wait that's something
chase I sneaked what does it call in
English seize her section
I was Caesar section so this baby could
be me it's like they're surprised that a
baby came out get birth
hi baby how was your baby hey there's a
baby let's kill it with a knife
apparently oh we got to cut there the
cord and put it away and a ladder better
more of that magic magic wake up
wake up good game good game
[Music]
Jesus Christ can we put it back in Oh
what else do we got to do to the stupid
baby
do we got to wrap it okay fine you're a
brick burrito now and then we eat it
that was it definitely worth the wait
oh how I've waited there's a better game
don't worry there's a much better one
there's a much much much better one
spank Elsa but how is this a kids game
this is on a kids game website spank
Elsa but look how ready she looks spank
me chimp oh my god I get to pick what I
spank her with Wow gameplay better than
Mass Effect Andromeda a belt a flip-flop
a ruler all right I'll start with the
hand see how that works
what just happened what just happened
she's crying you spanked the booty you
spanked the booty at 47 miles per hour
all right so what are your
qualifications to do this job mr.
Shelburn well you know I slept an ass
of frozen Elsa has an average of seven
hundred and seven miles per hour
yeah I'll be running this company now
thank you very much love the sound she
makes as well very good sound
the sheer terror for about half a second
then just mid cutoff my god 1220 what is
that in in kilometers because I don't
really know
wait that's 2,000 kilometers she she
will [ __ ] it will go through her that
will go through her I always wanted to
try spoon how about we do she screams
the same way even at 2 miles per hour
what is the slowest Bank we can give her
I don't know why I asked I don't know
why I asked what strikes me is that how
bizarre these games are for being kids
games they're so strange but obviously
there's a market for them but I don't
get it I don't get it moffat calm the
best free girl games online Jesus Christ
just like Jesus Christ what is the best
ones
moffat calm the best free girl games
online you said that it's almost like
the Simpsons you know they've done
nearly everything like frozen - Elsa
dolphin how how does that make any sense
oh my god that's really breastfeeding
what the [ __ ] oh my god the baby
here's the phone 9-1-1 amazing here's a
blanket okay have some water
oh my god have a bail have an oxygen
mask always ready you know always always
ready oh I got a man his shoulder stats
[ __ ] she's running out of water she's
running out of water
she's running out of what is this like
sniff but it's actually terrifying
because the consequences are real give
her the bound give it a bell why is she
dating Jack Frost I shot
I thought she was dating someone else ah
when the seal ambulance coming
we're having a baby we're having a baby
god damn it oh thank god
go to the hospital oh my god my card
i I don't think oh my god the baby sap
the baby's out the baby's out everyone
oh it's all disgusting take a sponge
take a sponge it's it's way better than
a baby trust me you don't want to you
don't want a baby you want a sponge oh
[ __ ]
ah can you make it Shh you know what I
find there's actually to be quite an
educational buy my baby have some drugs
you'll you'll feel bad I have another
one
now if we can only make the baby be
quiet my god oh my god breastfeeding is
normal breastfeeding is normal and you
should be able to do it in public it's a
kids game everyone it's a kids game I
know how to play a kids game okay I'm
smart enough I don't know anymore I just
don't know anymore
I'm starting to reconsider you know oh
my god what's wrong with their eyes
what's wrong with her eyes are they like
that in the whole game what's wrong with
her eyes
no okay oh my god she's so scary I hate
her what is wrong with her what is wrong
with her eyes what happened what is the
game about keemstar was here apparently
I think she took drugs she made a mess
and we have to clean it up for her and
she's looking at me and I'm scared I'm
scared of what she will do to me she
peed on the [ __ ] ground she peed
where do i broom there we go
okay I got it I got it I know how to
play a kids game okay I'm smart enough
we got to glue this now we'll just throw
it away the table was like that we gotta
fix the table Hey yes it's very detailed
this game you know if he put as much
detail in as the eyes it would have been
great if they did that but she wrecked
the place like what what did she do she
sped at the mirror why would she do that
good job thank you text if only I could
get the validation from from Anna then
then it would mean something nice don't
patronize me
okay I know you don't mean it thank you
my castle is clean out she sought it she
didn't say it she just thought it you're
welcome
can I go now please how can kids play
this and not be traumatized other than
the ice again the ice the [ __ ] ice
what did you know I know what did you do
and I why are you looking so happy dad
take this [ __ ] boy watch the [ __ ] up
snow blows side of the mountain air not
to be seen a kingdom of isolation and it
looks like I'm the queen the wind is
howling like this
we got spark you up we're gonna sprack
you up we're definitely concealing oh
I'm gonna end it here cuz I think I'll
go insane if I keep playing and I think
I'm worried about you as you as well but
yeah I hope you enjoyed this adventure
with me I hope you had fun leave it like
if you enjoyed all this appreciate it
all the support that I get and I'll see
you bros in another one brofist